Льодовиків меншає - дерев має більшати.
Адже через глобальне потепління містам бракує тіні, і вони  перегріваються.
Тож, у Німеччині політика захисту дерев - дуже сувора, а озеленення міст - популярне.
Теоретично зрубати дерево дуже легко.
Утім, на практиці - це довгий бюрократичний процес,
недотримання якого загрожує величезними штрафами - від 25 до 50 тисяч євро.
Законом захищені передусім листяні та хвойні дерева.
Місцева влада сама визначає, якого об'єму та висоти.
Наприклад, у Берліні під захистом перебувають дерева
завтовшки від 80-ти сантиметрів та заввишки від метра тридцяти.
З 1 березня до 30 вересня, як правило, заборонено рубати дерева.
Таким чином закон захищає птахів, що в'ють гнізда.
Власники дерев - чи то приватні особи, чи міська влада -
мають дбати про свої дерева та регулярно здійснювати контроль.
Приміром, чи здорове дерево або чи не загрожує безпеці оточуючих.
Влада винаймає спеціальних контролерів,
які оцінюють стан кожного дерева та вносять дані у електронний кадастр.
У ньому перелічені не лише усі дерева того чи іншого міста, їхній вік, форма крони,
місце розташування, але й усі дії, які відбувалися з деревом - оцінка стану, обрізання гілок тощо.
Такий контроль спеціалістів та догляд за деревами недешевий.
Утім, значно дорожче обійдеться відшкодовувати збитки, якщо дерево завдасть комусь шкоди.
Ще на етапі видачі дозволу на будівництво
відповідні органи повинні подбати про долю дерев довкола будмайданчика.
Якщо дерево таки приносять в жертву будівельному об'єкту,
то забудовник повинен відшкодувати збитки -
а саме висадити інше дерево певного виду та розміру або заплатити гроші.
Сума відшкодування може коливатися до тисячі євро. Рішення ухвалює місцева влада.
Дерева, які вдається зберегти, підлягають особливому захисту під час будівництва.
Наприклад, крону можуть обнести сіткою, щоб не пошкодити будівельним транспортом.
Поблизу дерев не можна складати будматеріали та шкідливі хімічні речовини.
Особливо дбають про те, щоб не пошкодити коріння і не перекрити йому доступ до води.
Усі ці заходи заздалегідь прописані у дозволі на будівництво.
Дерева на приватних дачах чи у садах не можна рубати без дозволу влади,
якщо обсяг їхнього стовбура перевищує 30 сантиметрів.
Ця норма не стосується фруктових дерев.
Якщо дерево виросло на межі двох садів, то воно належить обом власникам,
відповідно обоє повинні дати згоду на те, щоб його зрубати.
Щодо дерев біля багатоквартирних будинків - усе ще складніше.
Навіть якщо сад належить одній квартирі,
згоду на вирубку дерева повинні дати більшість мешканців будинку.
Нині у Німеччині в тренді - озеленення.
Адже дерева забезпечують жителів переповнених міст не лише киснем та тінню,
але й запобігають повеням, які дедалі частішають через глобальне потепління.
У Берліні каналізація опинилася на межі можливостей через обсяги дощової води.
Тож влада розробила концепцію міста-губки, відповідно до якої саме дерева і газони,
зокрема на дахах чи фасадах мають вбирати дощову воду.
У Німеччині немислимо вирубати парк під забудову, як це часто відбувається в Україні.
Навпаки, на вільних ділянках віддають перевагу створенню зеленого громадського простору.